I guarantee you that at some point
everything's gonna go south on you
you're gonna say this is it this is how
I am commander Marcus dead now you can
either accept that or you can get to
work this will come as quite a shock to
my crewmates and to NASA into the entire
world but I'm still alive
surprise here's the rub it's gonna be
four years for another mission to reach
me and I'm gonna have designed the last
31 days but if I can't figure out a way
to make contact with NASA but none of
this matters anyway my mom won't be
still alive Wow
in your face Neil Armstrong
okay I got to make water and grow food
on a planet where nothing grows it's
going to starve to death long before we
can help best so I'm gonna have to
science the hell out of this he's 50
million miles away from home he's
totally alone the hell is he thinking I
know I am the greatest botanist on this
planet I know how to save Mark Watney
but we need to Hermes crews are not
risking their lives it's bigger than one
person no no
NASA rejected the mission so if we do
this we're talking mutiny if anything
goes wrong
please do you realize how crazy this is
we had no other option
no matter what happens
until the world
to my family
never stop fighting
the Martian